[موسيقى]
مساء الخير من يصدق سقد الاقتصاد الالماني
العظيم في الركود واصبحت المانيا صاحبه
اكبر اقتصاد في اوروبا ورابع اكبر اقتصاد
في العالم تسمى برجل اوروبا المريض كيف
ولماذا وماذا يعني ذلك قبل محاوله الاجابه
يجب ان نعرف اولا حقيقه ما يجري في
المانيا الان اعلنت المانيا عن عجز في
حسابها الجاري اي انها استوردت اكثر مما
صدرت للعالم لاول مره منذ عقود في مايو
بلغ هذا العجز وقتها مليار يورو تجاوزت
المانيا هذا العجز سريعا وعادت لتصدر اكثر
مما تستورد كعادتها لكن الصادرات لا تزال
بطيئه والتضخم عنيد امام محاولات خفضه
بلغت تضخم في يوليو الماضي سته واتنين من
عشره مستوى مرتفع بالنسبه لدوله متقدمه
وشاهدت البلاد ثلاثه ارباع ماليه يعني تسع
شهور متتاليه من انخفاض الانتاج صندوق
النقد الدولي بيت ان المانيا سوف تنوي
بمعدلات ابطا من امريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا
واسبانيا على مدى السنوات الخمسه المقبله
اسباب تراجع الاقتصاد الالماني لا تخفى
على احد لانه يعاني من عده مشكلات بعضها
مؤقت مثل ضعف الاقتصاد الصيني ما يؤدي الى
انخفاض الطلب على الصادرات الالمانيه او
على البضائع الالمانيه
والضغوط المؤقته على قطاع التصنيع في
العالم كله المانيا واليابان وعدد محدود
جدا من الدول الصناعه فيها
المصدر الرئيسي للناتج المحلي الاجمالي
الصناعه بتمثل في المانيا 20% من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي يعني من كل مئه يورو
بيكسبها الالمان 20% من هذه المائه بتاتي
من الصناعه والصناعه بتتاثر اكثر من غيرها
بارتفاع اسعار الطاقه وارتفاع تكلفه
التمويل وفي السنوات او في الفتره الاخيره
ارتفعت اسعار الطاقه بشده وارتفعت تكلفه
التمويل نتيجه رفع اسعار الفائده في معظم
دول العالم النتيجه ان في صادرات صناعيه
او الصناعه بصفه عامه تاثرت في المانيا
اعطيكم مثال انخفضت الصناعات كثيفه
الاستهلاك للطاقه في المانيا زي المواد
الكيماويه والزجاج والورق بحوالي 17 في
المئه منذ بدايه الفين 2023 لكن في اسباب
هيكليه يعني طويله الامد مش مرتبطه بعنصر
مؤقت زي مثلا انخفاض الطلب في الصين واحد
البنيه التحتيه المتداعيه نسبيا في
المانيا هي البنيه التحتيه في المانيا
متداعيه مقارنه بدول اخرى نعم طب وليه
ببساطه لانه الحكومه الالمانيه بتتمسك
بسياسه التقشف المالي ولماذا يتقشف
الالمان قصه طويله خلاصتها ثقافه المانيه
بتؤثر الاد وتكره الاقتراض وتعتبر الدين
مرادف للذنب والمعصيه هذه الثقافه تحولت
لسياسه عرفت بعد الازمه الماليه العالميه
2008 بسياسه كبح الديون او ما يسمى في
المانيا بالصفر الاسود
ونص عليها الدستور الالماني في 2009 ووفقا
لهذه النصوص فان الحكومه الالمانيه ممنوع
عليها الا في ظروف استثنائيه من تجاوز عجز
قدره
يعني اقل من نصف واحد في المئه من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي الثانوي اي عجز عجز
الموازنه للحكومه الفيدراليه يعني الحكومه
الفيدراليه غير مسموح لها ان تتجاوز
مصروفاتها عن وارداتها باكثر من اوبو
بوينت 305 في المئه اثنين الضرائب
المرتفعه
المانيا يعني منذ سنوات طويله الضرائب
فيها اعلى من دول مجاوره لها معدل الضريبه
الفعليه على ارباح الشركات بيبلغ
28.8 مقارنه بمتوسط دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
البالغه 18.8 في فرق 10 في المئه على
ارباح الشركات
السبب الثالث هو الشيخوخه المتزايده بين
السكان المانيا مثل اليابان ايضا دوله
عجائز 46 سنه هو متوسط عمر الالمان
المانيا دوله لا تنجب كثيرا
وتوقعت دراسه صادره عن المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ان عدد سكان المانيا سينخفض بنسبه 14 في
المئه بحلول 2060 النتيجه في الوقت الحالي
ان 40% من اصحاب العمل يجدون صعوبه في
الحصول على عمال مهره هذه المشكله تزيد
يوما بعد يوم في 2 مليون مواطن سيبلون سن
التقاعد خلال خمس سنوات من الان وهناك
صعوبه في ايجاد من يحله مكانهم وبما انه
الالمان لا ينجبون بما يكفي الحل الطبيعي
في استقبال مهاجرين لكن هذا الحل بيصطدم
بطياري يميني متشدد كاره للاجانب مش عاوز
اجانب يجوا المانيا يبقى ما فيش خلفه وما
فيش مهاجرين في متاعب اقتصاديه اربعه
البيروقراطيه طبعا مره تانيه مقارنه
بالدول المتطوره مش بالدول المتخلفه
بالنسبه مقارنه بالدول المتطوره بيستغرق
الحصول على ترخيص لتشغيل شركه في المانيا
حوالي 120 يوم وده ضعف المتوسط في دول
منظمه التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه
اضف الى العوامل الاربعه دول التحديات
التكنولوجيه والجيو سياسيه التحدي
التكنولوجي بيتمثل في انه المانيا تاريخيا
عملاق في الصناعات التقليديه
زي الصناعات التقليديه زي الادويه زي
الاجهزه الكهربائيه وطبعا زي السيارات
وخصوصا السيارات التي تعمل بالطاقه
التقليديه يعني البنزين لكنها لم تركز
كثيرا على البرمجيات والصناعات المرتبطه
بها تخلف المانيا نسبيا مره اخرى في صناعه
البرمجيات ليس جديدا كلنا بنذكر التعبير
اللي قالته المستشار الالمانيه انجيلا
امريكا في 2013 لما وصفت الانترنت في 2013
يعني من عشر سنوات فقط بانها ارض جديده او
منطقه مجهوله للجميع
اثار موجه من التعليقات الساخره الان
الوضع اصعب مع تركيز الدول المنافسه على
تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي وبشكل عام ما زال
استثمار المانيا في تكنولوجيا المعلومات
كحصه من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي اقل من
دول منافسه زي الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
وطبعا
اعتماد المانيا الكبير جدا على الانتاج
الصناعي التقليدي جعلها تعتمد على سلاسل
التوريد العالميه وتحديدا مع الصين وروسيا
انهار هذا النموذج مع وباء كورونا والغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا وهذا بياخذنا للتحدي او
السبب السادس لمتاعب الاقتصاد الالماني
وهو التحدي الجيوسياسي
باختصار اعتمد الاقتصاد الالماني في نهضته
على الاقل في الثلاثين سنه اللي فاتت على
ثلاث دول الولايات المتحده التي وفرت لها
الامن وروسيا التي وفرت لها الطاقه
الرخيصه والصين التي قدمت لها ايدي عامله
رخيصه واهم سوق لمنتجاتها السوق مفهوم اما
الايدي العامله فالمقصود بها ان
المستثمرين الالمان اتخذوا من الاراضي
الصينيه مقرات لمصانعهم للاستفاده من
الايدي العامله الرخيصه هناك هذه الصيغه
التي نجحت لعقود تنهار الان لان الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي يضغطان لحرمان
الالمان كليه من الغاز الروسي وتسعى
واشنطن لاضعاف علاقه حلفائها بالصين املا
في اضعاف الصين
في الوقت الحالي اكبر مشاكل المانيا هي
الطاقه او اكثرها الحاحا هي الطاقه وهي
مشكله مركبه نتيجه عن التزام الحكومه بان
تكون دوله محايده للكربون بحلول عام 2045
اي ان تخفض من انبعاثات الكربون بتقليل
استخدام الوقود الاحفوري وتزيد من
الاعتماد على الطاقه النظيفه كان من
المفترض ان يكون الغاز الروسي ومحطات
الطاقه النوويه اهم مصدرين للطاقه في
المرحله الانتقاليه حتى 2005 لكن ضغوط
انصار البيئه اسفرت عن اغلاق معظم محطات
الطاقه النوويه والعقوبات على روسيا بعد
غزو اوكرانيا حرمت المصانع الالمانيه من
الغاز الروسي البدائل مثل الغاز المسال من
امريكا او غيرها اغلى بكثير وبالتالي
اسعار الكهرباء في المانيا اعلى من معظم
الدول الجوار النتيجه هروب الكثير من
الشركات الى دول اخرى حيث الطاقه اكثر
وفره وارخص سعرا مثل السعوديه وامريكا احد
بنوك الاستثمار الالمانيه قدر في اغسطس
الماضي ان المانيا قد تخسر ما بين اثنين
الى ثلاثه% من قدرتها الصناعيه بسبب قيام
الشركات بنقل عملياتها الى هذه البلدان
اكثر الصناعات المتضرره هي السيارات طبعا
لانه السيارات هي قاطره الصناعات
الالمانيه
شكلت السيارات حوالي
15.5% من قيمه البضائع المصدره في 2022
هذه الصناعه العملاقه هناك بتواجه
بالاضافه الى كل المشكلات السابقه منافسه
في غير صالحها من شركات صينيه بتبتكر
تكنولوجيات جديده ارخص خصوصا في قطاع
السيارات الكهربائيه السريع النمو واللي
المانيا حتى الان لم تتفوق فيه على كثير
من منافسيها سواء في اوروبا او طبعا الصين
هذه التحديات ليست محل خلاف بين الحكومه
ولا المعارضه ولا بيوت الخبره المستقله
الكل يجمع على ان الاقتصاد الالماني يعاني
والكل يقرب الاسباب السابقه الخلافه
الرئيسي هل هذه المتاعب مؤقته ويمكن
تجاوزها ام انها باقيه وسوف تظل تشوه
الاقتصاد الالباني وتدفعه خارج الحلبه
تدريجيا امام القوه الاخرى المنافسه
الرايين موجودين اي المتفائل والمتشائم
متفائل بيتفق مع روبرتايبك اللي هو وزير
الاقتصاد الالماني ونائب المستشار
الالماني اللي كاتب مؤخرا مقالا في راى
فيه ان وصف المانيا برجل اوروبا المريض
مبالغه والوصف الادق من وجهه نظره ان
اقتصاد المانيا ليس مريضا وانما مجهد
قليلا التعبير اللي استخدمه تحديدا
جستسلايتلي يعني مش في الفورمه زي ما
بيقولوا على الرياضيين شويه صغيرين يقرر
الوزير بالتحديات الكثيره التي تواجه
اقتصاد المانيا تحديات السياسيه والتغير
المناخي وصعوبات الانتقال للطاقه النظيفه
والتغير الديموغرافي عن السكاني ونقص
الكفاءات المهنيه والبيروقراطيه الزائده
الى لكنه يقول لدينا نقاط قوه كثيره منها
عدد ضخم من الشركات
متوسطه الحجم اللي بتتمتع بقدرات عاليه
على الابتكار والصناعه عميقه يعني ايه
صناعه عميقه يعني تصنيع المنتج النهائي
وكثير من المكونات اللازمه للوصول لهذا
المنتج النهائي محليا وموقف مالي صلب يمكن
الحكومه من اتخاذ خيارات متعدده لحل
مشاكلها والحكومات اللي بتتمتع بموقف مالي
صلبي يعني عندها فائض في هذا العالم الان
يمكن ان تعد على اصابع اليد الواحده
وبيضيف طبعا اخطانا وبدانا العلاج ضد
امثله كثيره على مشاكل تغلبت عليها
الحكومه الالمانيه منها انهم تغلبوا على
اعتمادهم الزائد على الغاز الروسي وقاموا
ببناء بنيه تحتيه جديده للغاز الطبيعي
المسال في وقت قياسي وتوسعوا في
تكنولوجيات الطاقه المتجدده والشبكات
اللازمه لها واقتصاد الهيدروجين الاخضر
الى اخره وتوقع ان اسعار الكهرباء في
المانيا سوف تنخفض بشكل كبير في السنوات
المقبله
واختصارا للوقت تحدث كثيرا
ثم اعطى امثله على نجاح الحكومه رغم كل
الصعوبات ومن بين الامثله اللي تحدث عنها
انه الحكومه استطاعت ان تقنع 24 شركه بضخ
حوالي 80 مليار يورو في عام واحد
استثمارات جديده والاستثمارات ديت هي
الاستثمارات الكبيره اللي الحد الادنى لكل
منها 100 مليون يورو اما الاقل من ذلك فلم
يدخل في حسبه الوزير
وتحدث ايضا على انه كثير من المشكلات
جاريه حلها زي محاوله اقناع المتقاعدين
بالعمل لفترات اطول وحولت اقنعهم بذلك
محاوله التغلب على القيود المفروضه على
هجره الايدي العامله الماهره الى اخره
واشار الى نفس المثال اللي اشار اليه
المستشار الالماني انه ايضا من بين عوامل
او امثله نجاح الحكومه الالمانيه هو اقناع
شركه انتالا الامريكيه وتي اس ام سي
التايوانيه ببناء مصانع ضخمه في المانيا
لتصنيع اشباه الموصلات وبيخلصوا الوزير
الى ان علاج كل هذه التحديات
سيتطلب وقتا وتكلفه اقتصاديه قصيره الامد
لكن المانيا قادره على استعادتها عافيتها
هذا الراي يؤيدهم كثير من بيوت الخبره
التي ترى ان المانيا وصفت منذ 25 عاما
بدايه من عام
1999 برجل اوروبا الم ريض لكنها تجاوزت
ازمتها السابقه بحزمه مذهله من الاصلاحات
طبعا اذكركم ان من سنه 99
وعام 2000 و2021 و2002 و2003 كان الاقتصاد
الالماني ماذوم بشده لعده اسباب اهمها
التكلفه الهائله لتكبدها هذا الاقتصاد
الكبير من اجل اتمام وحده المانيا بدايه
من عام 98
لكن بعد حزمه الاصلاحات المذهله تمكن
الاقتصاد الالماني من تحقيق اداء هائل بين
عامي 2006 و2017 ثم بدات المتاعب مره اخرى
بدايه من 2017 ووصلت ذروتها الان
كفريق اخر يعتقد ان المشكله هذه المره
اعمق وان الالمان لم يواجهوا في التسعينات
وبدايه القرن ال 21 منافسه بهذه الشراسه
من الصين ولا من الهند ولم تكن المشكله
السكانيه بهذه الحده ولا معدل تاخر
المانيا عن منافسيها في البرمجيات بهذا
الاتساع ولا التيار اليبيني المتطرف الذي
يعرقل حركه الهجره الضروريه بهذه القوه في
مواجهه ائتلاف حاكم منقسم على نفسه لننتظر
ونرى اي من الفريقين ادق في تشخيص اقتصاد
المانيا العظيم مجموعه ملاحظات سريعه كل
ما قلناه لابد ان يبدا وينتهي بكلمه نسبيا
تراجع نسبي في الاقتصاد الالماني ضعف نسبي
في الاقتصاد الالماني انخفاض نسبي في
الاقتصاد الالماني اذ يظل الاقتصاد
الالماني هو رابع اكبر اقتصاد في العالم
الالماني حوالي اربعه واربعه من عشره
تريليون دولار للتقريب هذا الرقم يساوي كل
اقتصاد قاره افريقيا مضاف اليه اقتصاد
السعوديه واقتصاد الامارات
ويظل متوسط دخل الفرد الالماني البالغ
حوالي
48.5 يعني 48 من نص الف دولار سنويا من
الاعلى في العالم وتظل المانيا تتمتع
بفائض مشرف في الحساب الجاري صحيح تقل
صفائض الحساب الجاري لالمانيا في 2022 الى
اربعه واتنين من عشره من الناتج البحري
الاجمالي مقارنه ب 7.7 في عام 2021 لكن
هذا الفائض بعد تقلصه ما زال رقما كبيرا
يعني بتتكلم على حوالي 180 مليار دولار
وال 180 مليار دولار دي تقريبا تساوي
الناتج المحل الاجمالي لكل من المغرب
وتونس مجتمعين وتساوي تقريبا
نصف الاقتصاد المصري اللي هو دوله كبيره
مكونه من 110 او 105 مليون مواطن مهما
تراجع الاقتصاد الالماني بهذه المعايير
سوف يظل واحدا من اكبر اقتصادات العالم
واحد اهم قلاع الصناعات الهندسيه ان لم
يكن اهمها على الاطلاق وهذا وضع طبيعي
لدوله تؤثر الادخار على الانفاق والاسراف
السفيه والعمل على الفحلاوه وما معنى
الفحلاوه يعني ادعاء العلم والمعرفه وعدم
الجديه وعدم احترام العمل وهو دي القيم
الشائعه في كثير من الدول المتخلفه
اقتصاديا الخطر الحقيقي الذي يهدد المانيا
هو صعود التيارات اليمينيه المتطرفه التي
قد تنحرف به الى مسارات سوداء وهذه قصه
يطول شرحها
الملحوظه الاخيره مقال وزير الاقتصاد
الالماني مثال للمسؤولين في بلادنا الرجل
مثل اي سياسي اراد الدفاع عن حكومته واشاد
بادائها لكنه لم يستفز الناس ولم يبصق على
المنطق بالتنصل من كل مسؤوليه قال تعلمنا
من اخطائنا ونسعى العلاج اوجه الخلل
اشكركم والى لقاء